[Música]
buenas noches
yo vengo de acá está la casa de las
historias un espacio donde contamos
cuentos pero fundamentalmente de la
tradición literaria de libros de la
literatura universal cuya lectura hoy
tiende a desaparecer
somos panas colombia me pidió que
narrará un fragmento del diario de anna
frank
nace en alemania de padres judeo-alemán
es su familia es una familia alemana que
lleva en alemania cientos de años ella
es hija de un padre que tiene una alta
posición en un banco de una madre que es
ama de casa pertenece a un mundo burgués
y culto
en el año de 1933 cuando el partido de
hitler de adolfo hitler sube al poder
hay una inmigración de judíos una
cantidad una masa de judíos que sale de
alemania hacia holanda eso hace la
familia frank
y ahí comienza nuestra historia en
holanda el padre funda una empresa de
mermeladas y de especies y anna y su
hermana margot entran al colegio
montessori anna es una niña
extraordinaria es una niña vital
interesada por todo excelente estudiante
le encanta el teatro le encanta el cine
le regalan su diario de cumpleaños ella
lo empieza a escribir un mes antes de
tener que esconderse
porque este mundo maravilloso e idílico
que ella vive se derrumba en el momento
en que alemania invade holanda en el año
de 1940 comienzan prohibiciones para la
población judía como no poder utilizar
el carro no poder utilizar el tranvía
anna tiene que entregar su bicicleta no
tienen entrada al teatro no tienen
entrada al cine
anna no tiene entrada al parque donde
acostumbraba a patinar en hielo
una de las entradas más conmovedoras del
diario es la despedida de su profesora
montessori del colegio montessori que le
dice no te puedo seguir enseñando tienes
que ir a un colegio especial para judíos
es en este momento cuando la familia
toma una decisión que no se puede
calificar sino de valiente han decidido
que se van a esconder hasta que termine
la guerra llevan meses guardando en un
espacio ubicado en la parte de atrás de
la fábrica de otto frank del padre
muebles sábanas ropa libros
utensilios de cocina y están esperando
el detonante el detonante es el momento
en el que existen alguno de los miembros
de la familia que se presente en la
oficina de registro ellos saben que en
ese momento el próximo paso seguramente
son los campos de concentración y
entonces en el momento en que
efectivamente le llega una citación a
margot frank para que se presente en la
oficina de registro
ellos dicen nos tenemos que ir a
esconder y solo en ese momento le
comunican a dos días antes de tener que
partir y han
empaca como empaca una niña de 13 años
ella misma nos cuenta empacó sus rulos
las cartas de las amigas unas novelas
juveniles holandesas
su diario en su diario ella había
escrito
tengo padres amorosos y querendones
una hermana de 16 años parientes tíos
encantadores una treintena de conocidos
muchos admiradores una abuela a la que
amo
un gato
no me falta nada
pues yo tengo un tío de venezuela el
servido porque la situación de venezuela
ya está muy feo se siente súper feo
porque no entienden
que él se está desplazando acá porque
por este por la situación como digo y me
siento súper mal porque tiene que
abandonar su hogar
y su familia cuando viajamos de aquí de
venezuela para acá porque la cosa estaba
empeorando
[Música]
la gente se estaba muriendo
la comida cara con mi hermano y
yo tengo dos mamás hechas y las que
están venezuela la verdadera
la travesía no fue larga no tuvieron que
atravesar fronteras no tuvieron que
atravesar puentes ni ríos eran realmente
unas pocas cuadras
pero llevaban la ropa una sobre la otra
los bolsillos abarrotados de medias y de
zapatos los unos iban por un lado los
otros iban por el otro y además llegaban
a encontrarse a ese anexo ubicado detrás
de la fábrica y en el primer piso pues
más de una docena de empleados de la
fábrica de mermeladas y de especies y
ellos no sabían decir tenían que llegar
antes de que los empleados ingresarán a
la fábrica
además uno salieron por aquí los otros
salieron por allá los otros salieron por
allá no sabían con quién se iban a
encontrar en el camino
lo que los rodeaba realmente era la
incertidumbre
en su diario ana escribe
en efecto vivo todavía
pero no sé cómo ni dónde
no sé realmente quién soy
pues siempre miran que porque dicen que
los venezolanos que acá es que hay algo
que sé que es más fuerte que como que la
viruela bueno y sé que ellos están
volviendo a traer eso que ojalá los sur
se los llevaran y que están trayendo
encía
pero
normal que hacen como
y después no tienen comida entonces
decían como bueno cuando ya se presentó
antes le hicieron como que es necesario
la salud antes como
[Música]
y después a pesar de que no eran tadashi
graves pues yo creo que de pronto uno no
afectase a un poquito
lo primero fue hacerse invisibles
porque llegan sin contratiempo
afortunadamente llegan y no hay
empleados logran ingresar a ese altillo
lo que nos rodea es el caos
la madre y la hermana mayor
caen tendida sobre la cama como
paralizadas
anna y otto se encargan de comenzar a
organizar y lo primero que tienen que
hacer es poner una cortina negra sobre
la ventana
para que nadie los vea
ya se han hecho invisibles todos saben
pero todos se hacen
que no saben
ya ha habido la gran conferencia de
evian en el año de 1938 cuando los
países europeos se reunieron para tratar
de decidir qué hacían con toda esa masa
de población cool y judía que estaba
saliendo de alemania y tomaron una
decisión cerrarle las puertas
en su diario
y escribe no solo los gobernantes los
poderosos son responsables
de la calle también es responsable
decía cosas conferencias como muerto de
hambre que repitas a comer porque
veniste sangriento y todo ese tipo de
cosas
nos han dicho nosotros los venezolanos
actualmente las veces que me decían por
qué invadió a su país
y que me devolviera para allá porque
según ellos en la parte alta del
episodio para mí
portable
hasta creo que es caliente precio
por todo recuerdo lo que me dieron de y
que está pasando en mi país
la vida en el anexo es muy difícil sobre
todo porque está la gente de abajo de la
fábrica
todo el tiempo cómo caminan si se oye
tienen que caminar en puntas de pie es
cómo se ríen el baño solo se suelta
cuando la gente de la fábrica haya
salido en la noche ana tiene 13 años
pelea con su mamá todo el día y no puede
gritar no puede expresar es como una
tensión sorda y lo que está pasando
afuera tiene un nombre la señalización
la población ha sido registrada
señalizada encerrada en los guetos en su
diario anna escribe quien ha resuelto
que debemos ser excluidos de todos los
pueblos
es que no
como humillar a la gente porque la
familia de uno casi está igual yo creo
que podemos zapatos de ellos como
podemos ver está muy bien
entonces tenemos la oportunidad de
ayudarlos porque por qué no hacerlo
para mí la solidaridad
es ayudarle a las otras personas como
ayudar a una persona
que no tienen las edades
[Música]
como dije con mi amigo venezolano que no
lo maltrataran como
no lo entendieron
en el anexo viven comen duermen trabajan
se disfrazan para reírse
peter el hijo de la familia van pels y
las dos niñas frank resuelven desde un
principio que no se van a dejar atrasar
en el colegio entonces estudian
matemáticas gramática francesa anne hace
traducciones inclusive el señor dulce él
el dentista decide que va a organizar un
consultorio y les va a tratar a todos
los dientes
entonces en medio de esa tensión hay
vida y además hay cuatro holandeses que
al final de la guerra van a ser
condecorados porque son ellos los que
los sostienen los que les surten no solo
comida
vestido sino noticias de sus familias y
además se encargan de que en cada
cumpleaños cada uno de los miembros de
esas familias reciban un regalo
escribe en su diario
he sido favorecida con una naturaleza
dichosa
con alegría y con fuerza
cada día me veo crecer interiormente
siento que se aproxima la libertad
que la naturaleza es bella
y la verdad de quienes me rodean y
experimento hasta qué punto esta
aventura puede ser interesante
por qué habría de desesperar me
el día de su cumpleaños mientras está
escondida en el anexo
and recibe
flores
novelas juveniles holandesas unos juegos
de mesa
y una torta
[Aplausos]